nice to see you again so wonderful to
see you as well conan how are you
i'm fine uh i have to say i've been
doing this a long time you may be the
first guest i've ever talked to that
walked out
wearing a fanny pack
yes that's a nice shot maybe stunts many
studs just like us
three right right many stars studs
because we're studs
yeah i got it very very clever thank you
we have muffins yeah
no we're not we're not muffins uh okay
what do you keep in the fanny pack
uh i keep a disappointment
pops and dreams also i right now
actually i have um
a piece of broccoli do you have a piece
of broccoli in your fanny pack yeah
would you like some
no i really don't want i don't want
broccoli from your fanny pack broccoli
splits wonderfully
no no that's okay i don't want your
crotch broccoli
okay properly my crotch you're crotchly
not interested uh but once you just put
that back
there no one needs to have no one needs
to know we're cutting this right
no no no this is all in if you're gonna
enclose any vegetable in in leather make
it broccoli
oh yes absolutely that's many of the
bumper stickers yeah
yeah sure you were on a bachelor
in paradise the after show oh you know
it
yeah uh i'm curious are there many
dating shows in germany is that a
phenomenon in germany
yes we have them it's usually just like
a lady staring at a man staring at a
lady and then like an animal is there as
well and then commercials are there
and then we just copy your shows
that sounds terrible a man staring at a
woman stirring in an animal and then a
commercial
hello yeah well i guess you beat me
yeah pay-per-view on that sucker right
yeah now
would you would you yourself go on a
dating show all day long 24th of the 7th
it would be such a wonderful time conan
you can go there you can stare at the
ladies you may smooch all
of the ladies for free they may smooch
you in return and then you get a gift
flower basket
[Laughter]
so you're built for a dating show oh
right now the dating show yeah it's like
bionic robot of date machine
yeah open mouth insert romance